I think my mom's fully Florida now dude
she's losing it talk like this okay I'll
tell you she she calls me the other
night at like 10 o'clock at night and
she goes she saw this in this article
about a woman that was in a coma
I'm have you heard about this she was in
a coma and one of the orderlies like
raped her and got her pregnant and the
good woman had a baby while in a coma
best we had to feel it and had no idea
write something I feel the best way to
have two baby what is an epidural
epidural is a body coma right you just
don't feel anything right isn't that
what an epidural essentially does yeah I
guess so I mean if you wanted a baby hi
potato this is where I'm going first
time she's like if you hit the story to
go yet I go the terrifying it's such a
horrifying thing that she goes right but
here's what I think she goes listen she
does there's so many like unfortunate
women that can't have babies right there
yeah why can't we make coma surrogates
and just sign it up like an organ donor
if I'm in a coma I'll have your baby you
could just put it's not a bad idea it's
not the worst idea what's the deal with
vegetables I mean let's use it for
something or pull the plug is a
vegetable Jersey also vegetables didn't
really get you guys some vegetables
that's literally no
right now okay
it's either episode episode walks out
stubs toe on the threshold hey why are
we still a threshold it's not like if
you get married you actually carry a
woman your wife over a threshold I'm
interested
what's the border threshold where is
this going that's got a stupid yeah we
shouldn't have threshold storyline be
right
Sappho would do 15 minutes of funny on
the threshold how funny he had something
with the wife wife carryin I was doing
with the wife Carrie it was gonna be
good and that's the genius Seinfeld as
he keeps going but you know what I was
gonna come back with him I was gonna
come back with Kramer walks in and trips
over the [ __ ] threshold and then it's
like oh the threshold has come full
circle this is an episode of Seinfeld
see how unfunny it is but that's how
that's what it if you break down an
episode of Seinfeld make it funny it's
funny how cuz it's okay so your mom
thinks that we should rape women and
comas and then have children dude that's
what I was like I was like rape that's
what you're saying and she's like and
this was her line that I was like oh my
mom's fully lost it she goes they're
just laying there anyway these are
people who these are people who will
never wake up again
I mean who knows something about comas
you could be in a coma for three days
honestly that was kind of funny that was
kind of fun yeah and if that was an
episode of Seinfeld maybe it's that the
subject materials too soft for me to be
invested in like I don't care about
parking tickets I don't care about any
of this [ __ ] but if it was like women
and comas getting raped and like
becoming surrogates because they're just
laying there right you know
that was not gonna you don't I mean
that'd be kind of fire sign that entail
Kramer bust in the door the [ __ ] coma
unit
[Laughter]
[Applause]